ah what's up I'm Zach and today gonna be
dunking on Brendan all day that's not
gonna happen
[Music]
I think it'll be a lot of that alright
okay that's one in basketball there's
like no greater shame then just getting
thoroughly posterized just getting
grounded dust by like a highlight reel
dunk
this is big I obviously would never
really be able to dunk on anyone ever
this is a kind of a dream come true oh
I'll get it okay
oh yeah challenge accepted by this is
gonna be harder than I originally
thought it was well Brendon doesn't know
is that I've asked other people around
the office to help me out today it is
officially not I trust no one
I'll be seeing you all right yeah you
will yeah watch the can I trust you I
would never lie to you oh come on your
side all right well are you in tried
don't call me today Brendon has no idea
that you are involved in this at all I
am going to text him meet me in the
canteen they just took me to come to the
canteen for lunch lunch he will
immediately be alerted that something's
going on so I'm gonna try to hide by
like the lobby doors before the canteen
so that I can try to like dunk on him
right there if I get it then that's
great but if I miss it I'm gonna have us
all if you like ah man it didn't work ah
all right
the plan didn't work say like alright
let's just cut everything that's good on
you to have it but we'll keep everything
rolling let's do post thoughts and then
we actually will come to canteen where
you will be whenever you see the right
moment you just don't go no okay uh so
tell me what you uh or tell them I guess
what you saw I guess I should say I
failed the first dunk attempt and that
was close it's not gonna be that easy
dude now I feel betrayed what moment did
you know that there was it was a
two-part what was actually a few so one
[Laughter]
[Music]
that was closest down in the basket ha
ha I will be safe just kidding you win
round one all right and we're done thank
you everybody
I thought that was a lock we need to get
him to leave his desk and go in the
lobby when you think the time is right
you go for it oh and don't hurt him
hope I'm not too sneaky
well Merle she whispered zach is coming
I had it well I'd like to speak you we
please chat I'm a little curious what
there is to talk about what the hell is
that I have a big plan here's the thing
where you gone no no wait
we can talk can we yeah we can just be
chill points for the ball down then
we'll talk you missed your kill you mr.
Q look when you think the time is right
you go for it yeah we can just be chill
points for the ball down then we'll talk
[Laughter]
that's on me the hoop got destroyed if
anybody was curious as to whether or not
full effort is being given in this
challenge yeah I feel like that's been
answered I'm gonna fix this give it back
to you and I get one more big go at it
and that's on you Merle all right
okay it was clear to me that I wasn't
gonna be able to dunk on Brendan so I
decided to invite the whole company to
give it a try I have a lot of friends at
BuzzFeed so I'd expect a good turnout
zach has decided
we'll see once I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna hand this to that he wants to dunk
on me he's gonna have to fight me by
should we see if there any people only
just poke my hand okay no one showed up
okay well no and shut up good turnout
a manhunt that's what it's come to
[Music]
hey dude it's me wondering where you are
we gotta finish this you gotta finish
this video so you seen a guy with a
basketball hoop on his head so I gotta
at least try one more time
okay toxic all right I'm looking for
Brendan doll I literally you asked for
this
that's about when does this end is this
just since with 30 people dunking on me
at once I'm gonna send a shot in the
dark - Megan boy
[Music]
I'm winning this challenge is it huh
you and Jack me and Jack because that's
all I could find
sorry yeah well not okay all at once
come on there has to be an end time for
this this is it
everybody gets their final tries gets
their final try
[Music]
[Music]
oh is that where you going
yeah well ball your jacket where's the
jacket I always just have a big lump in
the back
[Music]
Andrew what'd I do to you man what'd I
ever do to you panic and threw it at my
nipple you know what I spent four hours
of this hey that Nets done
[Music]
at this point he's earned it
there's wait look at this chaos going on
here one dunk for everyone that's it
this is what you said 20 minutes ago
[Music]
we're gonna look at the playback and
that's it no that's it like take the
hoop off it's over you know what I have
issued no I'm blocking it inconclusive I
got in the way even if it's inconclusive
the challenge of the video was for you
to dunk on me which there is no proof or
evidence that that happened yeah I think
we have to admit that I won the
challenge
I think we have to admit that I won the
challenge I you did win that challenge
great okay you won that challenge
[Music]